[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy whose accent
is worse than both billy and lenny's in
this episode in this video we're
breaking down the boys season 3 episode
7. the entry is filled with easter eggs
a big backstory segment for billy
butcher and a lot of things just like
that which pull from the comics so sit
back shut up and get ready for a vort
news network special report where we go
through it all now after last week's
live stream exposing bought homelander
and soldier boy you pick up with a news
report by vnn this comes across like a
propaganda edit from the start and it
has the stars and stripes burning
suggesting that starlight wants to
destroy america however this also has
its own symbolism as homeland as cape is
of course based on the famous flag
ashley denies the claims that maeve is
missing and this episode actually clears
up that she's in a secure cell located
at an undisclosed location owned by vort
we can confirm this due to the swat team
members who wear vort's logo on their
shoulder pads due to what homelander
says about getting used to it this is
likely where he was raised and the white
cell looks very similar to videos that
we've seen of him as a kid now these
cells were built to be super resistant
and in the comics we discovered that
there was actually a nuke pointed at the
entire facility on the off chance that
one of them wouldn't play ball and they
had to destroy the entire thing
homelander was raised here without a
mother or father and this explained a
lot of his psychological issues in the
comics we discovered that he was cloned
from stormfront but i had a feeling that
they might have changed it up with a
pair getting it on in season 2. we
discussed how homelander could have been
cloned from soulja boy but in this
episode we learned that he's actually
his biological son the series has been
heavily laced with the idea of fatherly
relationships and this has been a motif
for characters like huey and his dad
mother's milk and janine stan edgar and
victoria billy and his father and so on
and so forth in episode six soldier boy
even talked about how he'd wanted to
have kids with crimson countess you know
a couple little boys raise him up to be
men
now
now i got nothing
this line almost gets played beat for
beat in this episode when homelander is
talking to maeve lots of similarities
going on here as they both want kids
there's a really [ __ ] up side to it
too soldier boy didn't really consent to
having a son and homeland also tells mae
that her eggs will be harvested so that
she won't have a choice either he says
one of the coldest lines in the season
in i'm not letting you live i'm keeping
you alive really messed up and i kind of
hope that she actually gets a happy
ending in the comics she was killed in
war tower during a fight with hellmanner
but they do tease here something else
that could happen maeve wants nothing
more than to be normal and with soldier
boys tripping someone of their powers
there could be a way for her to lose
them and get somewhat of a regular life
she's maeved up like made up that
homelander is wearing concealent due to
him having a bruise and as vanco said
if you can make god bleed
then people will cease to believe in him
now as i mentioned ashley says mavis in
rehab further carrying on this lie and
she also states that soulja boy died in
84 again sticking to the official story
ashley is now the ceo and she'd likely
have access to all the info including
the stuff about soulja boy she also
brings up starlight's connection to
kimiko and states that she's a member of
the shining light liberation army this
was the terrorist organization that
kidnapped kimako and her brother so that
they could be turned into supes to fight
for their army ashley says connect the
dots and shining light is of course
similar to starlight so as i've been
saying sirio was right stop we don't
know that's all no it's all it's all
connected don't interrupt again now i
think this very much shows that
homelanders plan of destroying the world
is all talk and that he needs to be
loved to the point that he'd never
actually carried out the boys comic
series was always pushed as the super
powered people's biggest weaknesses
being their own egos which he's
definitely a victim of he gets exposed
again by starlight in a moment that made
me literally punch the air i got you a
sum of a [ __ ] but he immediately
transforms to try and save face
homelander destroying the world is all
talk and therefore he runs spin on
starlight instead of immediately killing
her because he knows what the public
backlash would be like you damn chump
see you chump
we then go to soulja boy singing the
song if you want to be happy bye jimmy
sull he of course appeared on solid gold
the other week and the guy had a lot of
music success the song if you want to be
happy is basically about how you're
better off marrying an ugly woman like
ryan airy's dad as no one will want her
and yeah i don't know if that kind of
stuff would fly today especially cause
you you get offended by everything don't
you but i still love you you're my boy
blue a huge shout out to gary ramos for
pointing out that this music video is
parodying the robert mitchen album on
screen right now cheers you chump now it
turns out the legend produced it and
above his fireplace we can see the
payback movie poster that was used in
the promo material for the show hughie
is wearing a doobie brothers t-shirt and
we also learn about soulja boy's time in
the war much like captain america he was
used purely for propaganda and the
character was only created to sell war
bonds for the us cab of course ended up
actually getting involved in the
fighting whereas soldier boy was just a
pr stunt with him being an actor this
could also be riffing on john wayne who
made numerous world war ii movies but
he's gone down in history as being a
draft dodger however though this is
reported quite a lot as being the truth
wayne actually did try to register but
he was rejected because he had a wife
and four children soldier boy still
doesn't mind getting on with women his
age though and he can't fight the
feeling anymore to get in deep as we
hear aryo speedwagon's classic in the
background legend also references some
of the old stars that he's had which
includes jacqueline smith and jacqueline
bessette hughie again has no idea who
they are but they start in charlie's
angels and bullet respectfully in this
episode they're after mindstorm a
character that's a new creation for the
show he's basically a psychic based on
the likes of professor x and jason
stryker due to the character design i'm
leaning more towards the ladder and like
striker mindstorm can infect someone
with powerful visions that they end up
getting lost in he's living out in the
wilderness and is referred to as howard
hughes a major business magnate aviator
philanthropist and film director who's
regarded as being one of the most
accomplished people of all time however
as the years went on his mental health
started to decline and his ocd went to
extreme levels hughes once sat in a
darkened room just screening movies
non-stop for four months and he urinated
in bottles crapped in mason jars and
wore kleenex boxes for shoes basically
lived the life of a movie youtuber and
his personal hygiene slipped massively
resulting in him growing long hair and
fingernails he was heavily medicated and
using mindstorm's prescriptions they
managed to track him down soldier boy
also brings up that he needs more weed
which butcher uses to stop his ptsd from
triggering by that he gets one of the
common side effects of this which is
paranoia which i wouldn't actually know
about in case me mother is watching now
he ends up second guessing huey and
butcher which does have some foundations
as we of course know he was betrayed by
his team in nicaragua nicaragua still
got it what an
idiot i'll jump to frenchian chemical
going to mother's milk and he once more
wears a dmx t-shirt on top of the black
panther poster from last week there's
also one for huey newton and a picture
of barack obama also interesting
coincidence here mm lives in apartment
42 which is the same number that jackie
robinson had a number of 42s popped up
into the spider versus references to him
and since then i've just thought of that
whenever i see them in a show 42 is also
the meaning of life i'm moving on and we
could to butcher and go out in the woods
and they open up the trunk this is a
similar shot to earlier in the season in
which they were with mother's milk he's
gone now though and the group are very
much enabling each other butcher has
been criticized for turning kimiko into
a weapon and he's very much just using
soulja boy for the same thing they also
discuss soulja boys drug use and they're
also clearly hooked on compound b even
though we discover it's very much
killing them it's of course injected
much like heroin and it gives someone a
high for 24 hours making it have very
addictive qualities from here we jump to
black noir who's hiding out at a rundown
busta beavers which is what i used to do
when i was 20. buster b by now this
chuck e cheese parody was actually
advertised on the social media accounts
for the show all the way back in
february so we had some inkling that
this might be a location that showed up
buster beavers stutters like pop-up
porky pig and he brings up the black
noir massacre and lagos which has
already been touched upon in the season
this was a play on wander at the sun of
civil war who killed several wakandans
out in lagos really it was homelander
who got him through it but he thinks it
was these cartoon characters noah
imagines the animals coming back to life
and as we discovered in episode 3 he had
brain damage after the attack in
nicaragua this has taken him back to
having an almost child like mind state
and him retreating to this show is how
he very much finds comfort in his
childhood memories he also drew one of
the characters earlier in the season and
through them we learned what really
happened in
when soldier boy was taken away now
soldier boy is played by the eagle
character which of course represents
america's mascot whereas noir is a timid
sheep you also discover his name is
irving and i'm kind of sticking with the
theory that he could be a relative of
stan edgar after soldier boy sets off a
tripwire butcher is transported back
into his worst nightmare by mindstorm
this pulls several elements from butch's
origins story in the comics beginning in
omnibus 5 we see his childhood in the
arc titled bomb alley this entire arc
runs for six issues and it's centered
around billy going to his father's open
casket after the undertaker has done him
up for his funeral we learned that he
was a baker which butcher found
hilarious due to their surname however
their dad would kick the crap out of
anyone who made fun of it and billy used
to spend his nights listening to his dad
beating up his mother he would go to
sleep promising to kill him one day and
his anger inside spilled over into the
classroom he punched a teacher whilst
fighting another kid whereas in the show
he attacks one after he says he doesn't
want him to turn out like his dad now on
top of this they also have the scene
where his dad gives him a beer in the
show it's during a visit to the pub
whereas in the comics he cracks up in a
can for him in the basement of the
bakery it's during this conversation
that he says his brother is like his
mother raz billy is just like him these
words stuck with him for the rest of his
life and billy turning into his dad has
also been touched upon by grace mallory
shortly after this his father had a
stroke and one night his mother tried to
cut up his steak for him so he could eat
it easier he ended up breaking her eye
socket and for the rest of the story she
has a glass eye billy said he was gonna
kill him but lenny ended up talking him
down he said that it would break his
mother's heart and that if his dad died
he'd go to jail and they'd have nowhere
to live and also no money this line
about breaking hearts is brought up in
the episode and billy's grandfather also
says it to him when he toys with joining
the army realizing that he couldn't work
with his dad because he'd end up killing
him but she then joined the royal
marines and he fought in the falklands
war now i want to do a big breakdown on
his back story in another video but
that's pretty much how it plays out in
the comics in terms of what we also get
in the episode we learn that he's going
to be stuck in this until he starves to
death unless mind storm decides to free
him soldier boy says he better get that
idea out of his head otherwise he'll
slap him like he's connery sean connery
had an interview with barbara walters
where she'd asked him if he stood by his
statement on slapping women from a
couple of years prior he doubled down on
this and said he stood by it and that it
was fine if the circumstances call for
it now this idea of abuse of course
carries over to the flashbacks and we
see how billy hit his brother and took
the beatings for him lenny is someone
who has weighed over billy massively and
he's appeared in hallucinations
throughout this season at one point he
appeared on the tv for a split second
and he also flashed in place of huey
after they set soldier boy free billy's
room is full of football memorabilia
including flags of both west ham and
charlton athletic at one point in the
episode we can see a calendar that says
1989. charlton actually shared upton
park with west ham for a season and a
half explaining why he supports the two
teams billy's father's beating of course
mirrors his anger and as they've
discussed throughout the season the only
brings out what's inside of someone
already this is meredith kimiko who too
wishes to be injected with it once more
at mother's milk we see frenchie saying
it's the greatest sorrow of his life
that he missed here orgasm and he's
constantly baked it up throughout the
entire series they're trying to find a
way to take out soulja boy and i think
for the finale that he'll end up teaming
up with homelander can see the pair just
going wild and this will make the boys
rejoin forces in order to stop them both
who knows they might even end up getting
someone like black noir on their side
and he could lead them to maeve who will
join the fight so you kinda have mixes
of the seven the boys and also payback
this would mirror noir and homelanders
rivalry in the comics and i think it
would be such a cool way to take the
show in the future kimiko then sits with
annie watching michael cembello's maniac
from the movie flashdance this is later
given a second reference when we find
out that soldier boys slagged off black
noir to its producer don simpson now
kimiko focuses on the video for a bit
but rather than slipping off into a
fantasy she stays with starlight and
concentrates on the important things i
think this is truly symbolic of how
she's now accepted that she'll never
have the happy life she's fantasized
about and sadly she is the killer she
didn't want to be she needs to be strong
to protect frenchie and this puts
starlight in the position where she has
to return to vote tower back with huey
and soulja boy the latter says that
butcher must suck like a hoover deluxe
for him to constantly look out for him
and this classic device had the suction
power of ryanary's mom on a friday night
i got you again you chump shut the [ __ ]
up ryanairy now huey also mentions his
marlboro act man which is a reference to
the video at the start of the episode
which was based on classic cigarette
adverts from here we jump to the deep's
waterbed it's not but it would have been
cool if it was and either way he's found
out he's about to be on sean hannity and
to celebrate this fox is about to get
wet wet wet time for some tentacle
as we watch deep suggested threesome to
the song more than words by extreme it's
an extreme scene and deep says that the
octopus ambrosia wants to taste
cassandra and i guess that's how with a
squid you get eight like taste in eight
i'll stop with the puns now deep also
mentions that dave edgar says he has
formidable intellect and the author was
behind the bug a heartbreaking work of
staggering genius back with black noir
the animals act out his time with
payback at ford american this was the
name of the company in the comics which
was then shortened to vote for the show
but it's nice they gave a slight call
back to its prior name in the flashback
to the past soulja boy beats the crap
out of gunpowder and as we learned in
episode 3 he was abusive towards him
noir then storms in angered that soldier
boy had him dropped from beverly hills
cop i was born to play axel foley why
would you say all those horrible things
about me to don
simpson now axel foley is the name of
the character that eddie murphy played
and noise said in episode three that he
wanted to be the next team sadly uh
black members still none start to blow
the mason dixon well i could be bigger
than that i could be eddie murphy
as mentioned earlier soldier boy
badmouthed him to the legendary don
simpson who was a producer for not only
beverly hills cop but also top gun bad
boys the rock and of course flash dance
sergeant boyce smashes his face and like
you should smash that like button and
this idea of him being upstaged of
course plays into the ending where as he
didn't want noir to replace him come the
end of the entry he seems to genuinely
want homelander to succeed him player
ronnie comes across a priest and a nun
out on the road in one of the funniest
scenes in the entire season i love how
he just starts shooting and says they're
brainwashed by mind storm and you kind
of go back and forth over where the
soldier boy is just paranoid turns out
he's justified though and we get a
hilarious jump scare that ends in a
black and white and red all over joke
it's the way i tell him and next we see
homeland there at a robert singer
election rally where he spins
starlight's house for runaway teens as
being tied to the shining light
liberation army as a location that
trafficks children to their organization
bills on ashley's statement from before
and this clearly convinces todd who's at
the rally with janine throughout we see
victoria newman watching homelander like
a hawk which further calls back to when
he arrived at the rally in season 2 and
she wouldn't take her eyes off him now
that we know she's the head popper this
adds a lot of extra context to it
homelander also points out the media's
cameras at the rally which i believe is
meant to be a nod to when donald trump
did the same thing at one of his
homeland ends the speech by saying vote
bob singer and this is a great
supernatural easter egg now robert
singer are you listening well robert
singer it's good easter egg he in the
show he's played by jim beaver now jim
beaver also starred in supernatural and
he played the character bob singer
supernatural also star jensen ackles who
plays soldier boy and it was produced by
eric kripke who runs the boys so as
we've been saying it's all connected
now after stressing out over a
hallucination of soulja boy homelander
ends up going to milk a cow this further
plays into the fact that he never had a
mother or father in his life homelander
developed his fascination with milk in
season one when stillwell breastfed her
son and he got jealous of the baby
having a mother in the background we can
hear crimson and clover by tommy james
and the chandelles but this moment of
pieces interrupted by victoria newman
similar to last week with starlight she
wants to work with homelander but
instead of getting rejected he seemingly
sides with her she hands over a piece of
yellow paper which we later see has an
address on it i'm guessing that this is
the location of ryan and i'd imagine for
the season finale that homelander
catches up to him stop it's theory time
now we get some foreshadowing to
victoria's potential arc in the series
with us later singing news report for
lamar bishop who's the favorite to be
the vice president in the comics
victoria's counterpart victor veep ended
up taking the position after he was
planted there by vort so my guess is
that this news report is shown to us to
introduce the vice president pick in
order for him to be taken out by
victoria so that she can replace him
vort were desperate to get vic to become
the president so that they could rule
over the entire country with their
inside man and if she does get that
position i think she'll end up killing
dakota bob much like how viktor veep
killed him in the comics anyway that's
their time dear time new time might not
be true see your time so don't don't
lose your sh if we get it wrong cause
it's just a theory of an idiot
now we go to a train in the hospital and
i was so glad to see him back i know a
lot of people thought that he died last
week but i think keeping him alive was
the smarter way to go about it we
discovered that he's had a heart
transplant and now carries that of blue
hawks he doesn't exactly seem thrilled
by it and actually kind of bombards him
with all the plans that they have for
him this includes talking trash about
starlight and as we theorized soulja boy
is gonna take the blame for killing blue
hawk ashley says they also have a biopic
in the work for him starring tom hanks
as his running coach that's going to be
written by julian bellows hanks is very
much whitewashing the person who
actually trained him which is of course
his brother i do think a train won't
just fall back in line like this scene
paints out and i actually believe that
after last week's apology that he might
end up joining the boys in the fight
against soulja boy and also homelander
during the news report we also see that
there's a headline asking whether
starlight drinks adrenochrome this is
basically a form of adrenaline that was
tested during the 50s until the 70s and
it ended up causing schizophrenia
however in recent times it's also been
linked to pizzagate as being a substance
that was used in
well you know what it is now this ties
in a starlight home for runaway teens
and builds on the conspiracy theory put
forth by homelander frenchie finally
figures out that gas hasn't been
knocking out soulja boy and instead it's
vaporized nerve agent this is another
shark which is believed to have been
used to poison russian opposition leader
alexey navalny the footage in the video
of course made it seem like he was being
gassed but when milk tried this adhere
orgasm it just didn't work however this
will be a way to put him to sleep when
it comes down to it also this might be a
reach so bear with me but frenchie wears
a weird flowery orange top looks a bit
feminine and when we look at the stuff
that little nina has worn throughout the
series it is similar to something that
she'd have in her collection so i
actually think it might be one of her
clothes that they grabbed last week
after they managed to escape after
dancing to dream a little dream of me
kimiko explains why she wants feedback
and that they're more than just lovers
they're family a starlight steals some v
and after looking at the notes for v24
we get a split second flash of a
document for it if we slow down the
footage we can see that this causes
tumors along with atrophy which will
kill a user confirming why butcher and
billy's ears have started bleeding it's
lethal after three to five doses and
butcher at the end very much gambles
over whether to keep taking it now we
come back to bust a beaver and we see in
the scene that that couldn't react can't
pronounce and here we discover that it
was actually edgar who ordered the hit
on soldier boy edgar is portrayed as a
weasel and he continuously eats almond
nuts in front of him which are of course
noise weakness showing that he holds the
power here he clearly knows soldier boy
is bad product and wants him out the way
so that they can try again with his son
we see what really happened and how
payback turned on soulja boy which led
to him burning noise face and smashing
his skull open so that his brain came
out this has left him unable to speak
and giving him a childlike persona a
strap on a vapour gas canister to his
face and it is possible that this tactic
will also be used next time to take him
out as we now have two scenes that
discuss this method milk then goes to
get janine and he punches todd after he
sees that he's trying to indoctrinate
her into politics he doesn't think
there's any danger with soulja boy and
as we've talked about in the other
videos the creative team discussed how
there would be metaphors for the
pandemic which are there if you want to
see them at least i think so anyway now
after getting a confession that he
killed supersonic we learned that stall
had actually lost 3 million followers
since the last episode last week newman
said that she had 193 million but she's
now dropped down to 190. still though
it's enough to expose him and it's going
to be interesting to see what the
repercussions of this are finally
soldier boy and huey come across
mindstorm's cabin which is littered with
wind chimes probably to distract him
from the fact he has people's thoughts
constantly entering his head huey
teleports him out of there and we can
see that this was part of his original
plan as he left a bag of clothes behind
so that they could get dressed we see
the final flash back in billy's head and
learn how lenny ended his own life this
alters things from the comics as in
those he was hit by a bus which happened
long after he'd grown up billy still
leaves for the army and he abandons him
uttering his dad's homophobic slurs as
he exits showing how he ended up
becoming him really heartbreaking scene
watching billy beg his younger self not
to go and though the accents sound like
some dick van dyke thing the emotional
beats work really well the gunshot
sounds his butcher snaps out of it and
he mistakes huey fellaini for a split
second the words about him getting
everyone killed who gets close to him
ringing his ear but soulja boy arrives
and kills mindstorm smashing his head in
similar to black noir it's also a very
similar death to how john walker killed
a flag smasher and falcon in the winter
soldier and mindstorm reveals homelander
is his son hughie also wears a footloose
t-shirt and soulja boy realizes that he
can't trust the pair they return to the
cabin and we also see a poster for the
countess's whiskey sunrise which is
similar to tequila sunrise starlight
rings billy in order to get through to
huey and he tells him the truth about
v24 as lenny said he'd get everyone
close to him killed and this is cemented
here when he doesn't warn huey about the
lethal side effects kimiko ends up
taking the refined version and her
wounds disappear showing that it worked
we then end with the darth vader moment
and this spins the whole show on its
head next time things are about to get
crazy no i don't think this quite topped
last week it was still an incredible
episode this season especially has
really knocked it out of the park and i
can't wait to see what they do next time
there's also a post-credits scene
involving the looney tune type
characters bowing and that's the end of
the video
and of course love to hear your comments
and what you think will happen as well
as any easter eggs that we missed we're
running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of everything
everywhere all at once on the 15th of
july and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the boys we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
westworld which will be linked on screen
right now the new season has just
dropped its first episode and we go over
all the easter eggs hidden details and
give
nothing but theory times about what the
hell's going on hopefully see over there
right after this but if not enjoy your
weekend take care peace